elles sont dévastées
et très fragilisées parce qu'il se passe
13h cet après-midi la famille Kurosaki
mère et sœur quitte le tribunal sans un
mot derrière elle Arthur delpiccolo le
petit ami de Narumi tous viennent de
vivre l'impensable le report du procès
[Musique]
Nicolas était là
décide de faire
quelques heures auparavant la tension
était palpable beaucoup redoutaient la
demande des nouveaux avocats de Nicolas
Zepeda un renvoi inédié à la barre
maître Porte-Joie se dit désarmée devant
un tel dossier plusieurs milliers de
pages impossible à avaler
le temps matériel pour prendre
connaissance du dossier ce sont des
jours voire des semaines on nous accorde
24 heures monsieur l'avocat général
proposant en réalité trois jours de
délai mais ça serait la même ma
difficulté donc concrètement nous ne
sommes pas en mesure de pouvoir assister
correctement monsieur Zepeda l'avocat
général Étienne mentaux qui a porté
cette affaire depuis le début n'en
revient pas selon lui Zepeda dicte le
tempo de la justice maître schwar dorfer
avocate victimes plus conciliant ne veut
pas d'un procès bâclé nous ne voulons
pas l'exécution de Nicolas zappeda non
pas l'exécution judiciaire de Nicolas
zapella personne ne le souhaite y
compris les magistrats professionnels
qui vont devoir juger cette affaire avec
les jurés de la cour d'assises de la
Haute-Saône nous souhaitons un vrai
procès si cela doit passer par un renvoi
cela passera par un renvoi après deux
heures de délibération la course stoppe
les débats et renvoie le procès Nicolas
Zepeda a obtenu ce qu'il voulait c'était
la seule décision raisonnable la moins
mauvaise décision et nous sommes
soulagés plutôt que satisfait que la
Cour nous est suivie dans notre
raisonnement il est d'usage en la
matière lors de renvoi de procédés de ne
pas mentionner de date probablement
septembre mais je ne peux pas m'avancer
l'avocate de la famille Kurosaki se dit
consterné par cette énième
rebondissement 6 ans désormais après la
disparition de Narumi
quand on est sur une ligne de défense
aussi rude il est évident qu'on ne peut
plus jamais espérer chien des aveux fins
ou même quelques révélations de quelques
natures que ce soit donc aujourd'hui oui
elles ont totalement perdu l'espoir
elles n'espèrent plus rien
surprenante épilogue d'un procès attendu
depuis un an Nicolas et péda est reparti
en prison en attendant une nouvelle
convocation